some of you will have seen Shawn and me
going wild around Bletchley Park and
will deduce from that that we paid a
visit to BP as they call it in the trade
it's time now for me to move off from
the enigma story which I've done two or
three videos on already and tell a story
this in many ways is even more relevant
to the start of computer science than
even enigma Wars we've all heard of Alan
Turing but I would suspect that fewer of
you have heard about Bill Tut max Newman
Tommy flowers but they're all worthy of
hero status because they are all
connected with a type of cipher traffic
mysterious driver traffic the came to
Bletchley parks attention and at
Bletchley was always called Tunney
traffic they love calling mysterious
traffic by the name of fish and was
things like sturgeon and halibut as well
as honey but this one is going to be
Tunney traffic Tony is the original
English word for what we nowadays call
tuna it's as simple as that even before
the war the Metropolitan Police and the
Foreign Office jointly used to listen to
the airwaves to see what was happening
you know that shouldn't be happening
within the UK shows anything mysterious
now an awful lot of course what they
were listening to was plain
straightforward radio broadcasts or from
the military point of view it will be
Morse code some of that Morse code might
well be encrypted Enigma traffic but it
was in Morse this one was weird it
wasn't in Morse it sounded almost like a
touch-tone telephone on steroids or
something it was me all over the place
and so what they did was they equipped
the listening stations all over the UK
because they all knew that war was
almost inevitable they had a whole load
of joint listening stations and these
listen for enigma traffic they also
listen for anything unusual they were
called Y stations Capital y for reasons
I don't understand but there again
Bletchley Park was called station X and
I don't understand that either so these
Y stations
say look there's some weird stuff here
would you like to see what it looks like
they were able to make a recording of
the trace of this as if it was an
oscilloscope but actually on a piece of
paper if you look here it's like a
waveform and that is exactly what it is
and they were able to record this as a
black trace and when you look at his
like a mixture between a sort of sine
wave and a square wave but once they got
the experts in looking at this you're
going to remember teleprinters were very
common they were used in stock exchanges
that were used in telegraphy a lot of
traffic went over land line that was
actually teleprinter code this was
broadcast because presumably the land
line was too long between the far end of
Greece and Germany let's say so it had
to be broadcast and that the expert said
that's broadcast teleprinter traffic
matters now you know why Sean and I have
set the seed by doing a video already on
five old paper tape codes teleprinter
alphabet and even on exclusive all the
rule had the police and the Foreign
Office's anything mysterious like this
gets sent to G CCS we remember from the
previous videos G C and C s government
code and cypher school initially based
in st. James's Park in London with a
great majority of it moves off to
Bletchley Park in the late thirties so
blessed park was accumulating this stuff
big debate is this a Vernon cipher in
the late 1920s an American employee of
AT&T had come up with the idea of doing
secure and ciphered teleprinter
transmissions by doing what we would now
call an exclusive or between two five
bit puns yeah great idea because it
would disguise the character you wanted
to send there's only one problem that if
you want to apply that to a whole
message
how would you arrange to have as it was
cipher key
characters randomly chosen to mix in
very exclusive or with your plain text
that you wanted to send and to send out
the result well what Vernon proposed and
to my amazement he patented it and he
this is madness
this is madness this is secure this they
shouldn't be patenting this stuff it
gives the game away this is 18 - and
we're not at war yet we're not having
the competition coming over this prize
idea this has got commercial potential
you know as well as military we're going
to pay some tit so Vernon patented the
idea it would use to five whole tapes
and what you could do is have this one
which is the plain text running
alongside this one which is somehow been
generated and this is the key this is
the thing that's going to be exclusive
odd character by character with this to
give a ciphertext the problem is the
enormous one these things are driven by
sprocket holes you start trying to run
two tapes simultaneously through a piece
of bespoke electronics which I invented
which will do the merging but you must
keep them in exact sync you do not want
differential stretching between the two
things
worse still when your supervisor says
this thing isn't going fast enough we
need more speed and you speed it up you
know what happens next the sprocket
holds tear and then you've got slippage
like you've never dreamed of in your
worst nightmares so as a result of all
this problem of tape synchronization it
never really got to market it was
quietly abandoned but the idea was good
but the people of Blasi parts I'd say is
this a Vernon cipher that we were taught
about at Training School before we
started here at BP but maybe the Germans
have been smart enough to say we're not
going to use a second tape because you
could have it synchronized we will
provide the key characters from a
machine it will be like an add-on to the
teletype the teleprinter you type in
your plaintext character this theme will
invent
and it's probably going to have we'll
throw two wheels every good cipher
machine has wrote Orioles on it would
somehow generate a 5-bit international
teletype letter and then it'll
automatically exclusive-or it and then
we'll get an output and that'll be our
cipher and the good thing is that it
will be a lot less problem to keep the
machine in sync with what we're doing
when you've only got one tape to worry
about so in the end they discovered that
that's exactly what was happening looked
at more and more this Tunney traffic how
on earth are we ever ever going to get
into this stuff at the start of this
signal it goes up high but the rule in
these intercepted messages that we'll
put out on this piece of cake called the
undulator is that if it's high it's a
zero and if it goes low it's a 1 and the
neutral point is somewhere in the middle
let's just do a straightforward addition
of two five bit codes to see what it
would look like the letter a capital A
in the International teleprinter code
the Bordeaux Murray code is one one zero
zero zero and let me remind you one of
the approved signals for doing an
exclusive or operation is plus in a
circle I'm going to add that on V
exclusive or to the letter X letter X is
1 0 1 1 1
you all know how this works now
exclusive-or gives a 0 if they're the
same and a 1 if they're different look
that up in your table what character is
that it's the letter V so there we are
look the plaintext shall we say was a
the ciphering character given by the
randomizing device was X and this
particular character is V what we're
going to have to do on this Shirley is
to get enough evidence about that random
t stream before we can start working out
how the heck it works mathematicians
were around and we're up on the scene
arguably not as many as Bletchley Park
really needed in the early
is to say look this is an example of
what we in the mathematics trade call an
additive cipher ciphering system it's
doing arithmetic modulo a certain number
this as I've said is arithmetic modulo
two is binary addition but without the
carries and some wise self said do you
know there are weaknesses in all
additive ciphers basically at the end of
the 19th century a man called kerkoff's
had published a paper about cryptography
in via and ative ciphers and said the
problem with them all is if you
accumulate enough captured ciphertext
even when you don't know the key but
lost different messages if they're all
done with the same key you can
eventually accumulate so much that very
clever trick you can work out what the
messages are without even knowing the
key because it kind of cancels out oh
that could be awful so all we've got to
look out for then is are they using the
same key for any of this stuff handy
every single one of these transmissions
before it came through on the undulator
they all came with an indicator now this
really puzzled them at first I copied
one down from my reference books those
12 characters would be sent out and then
there'd be a pause and then this stuff
the undulator traffic would start
however there was sufficient of this
sent out to train the operators that
again the game was given away the Crypt
analyst said I wonder if that's in in
code or cipher itself and so I don't
know BC could this be like enigma they
sent out blocks of three letters to show
the settings the initial settings could
it be like that and somebody else would
say yeah but there's 12 of them that
doesn't make sense
10 would make sense two layers of
encipherment one after the other first
row of five you know five bits and then
push it on again to another one but
these could be settings of so
four wheels just like enigma but how can
we be sure that they aren't in a code of
their own do they really mean what they
say as part of the training scenario
obvious for the poor operators trying to
work this machine there was some of the
transmissions that said in clear em East
Michael G is to Gerhart alright so by
the time you've got o is Auto K is Karl
right you can see this is training / -
yes it's k4 Karl you see the K and you
wind the cipher we're out of sugar let's
get K for call and by the fact that they
had elaborated in the training all of
these as boys first names made the
listeners sure that these were what they
seemed so the answer now is very clear
we have to sit and wait patiently we
have to ask our Y stations to rigorously
send us exactly what the indicator was
and if we wait long enough somebody will
use the same indicator twice absolutely
against standing orders but it was known
from enigma this was a great temptation
in the heat of battle with people
shouting at you you use the same
settings twice it's all right no but
you'll be listening oh yes they are this
did happen I guess you could say sooner
rather than later
I think it was August 1941 they finally
got a message which you got the same
indicator and they knew perfectly well
that with that when a lot of hard
patient work because were no computers
to help you nevertheless we could
probably disentangle this message now
another thing these messages seem to be
going between headquarters of the German
High Command these were not between
weather stations they were not even
between Luftwaffe stations this was
serious stuff which this was going from
Athens HQ to Berlin HQ shall we say
clearly this stuff and there wasn't much
of it initially was going to be used by
the higher-ups the German High Command
as we now know it really was Hitler's
favorite cipher machine
it's great advantage unlike enigma was
that it was user-friendly you know what
enigmas like you need a person to punch
the thing a person to read the lamps a
person to send the Morse code here you
could connect to encrypted type
teletypes back-to-back across a landline
or even across the airwaves although
that would be a bit dicey to do with
interference but you could in principle
have your operators never see the cypher
text it goes in one end and ciphered
across deep ciphered out it comes
therefore Costas is using user friendly
people will send longer messages and
that's music to the ears of the Crypt
analyst Prague aid they love that by
this stage the listeners had decided
that we needed a new Y station
separately for this tourney traffic
remember the traffic was called sunny
the machine that was generating it was
called German honey or just honey the
machines that eventually they built at
Bletchley Park once they understood how
it works to do the same job of
deciphering was called British honey but
it was all Tunney yes a so he was this
tiny traffic all stacking up all waiting
to be decrypted all waiting for two or
more to be sent out with the same key
now a Bletchley technically that's
called a depth getting a depth means
you've got two or more character
messages all with the same key
absoulutely against standing orders
because the german cryptographers had
warned the military this one this kind
of XOR additive cipher is even more
sensitive to depths probably even than
enigma within it we only got a short
message out anyway because life's too
short to send much more than about 50
carats this thing in the end they got
4000 characters worth and then when they
said when the chap phoned back that I
said sorry didn't quite get that could
you send it again my first thought was
surely the sender guy would have had the
cents to make a tape of it and to send
it offline in the first place
no we hadn t typed it in by hand without
making a copy so when it was sent again
you can imagine the sender muttering and
cursing used abbreviations he made it
shorter and as we'll see next time that
made the deciphering job even easier
zero zero two one and so on
and the important thing about this is by
doing this we're going to get a huge
list of noughts all in a row and that is
very easily compressed by Huffman
encoding most of our volunteers have
been building the circuits at home on
kitchen tables in garden sheds